un proceso electoral sin posibilidad de
sorpresas las autoridades prórrosas en
las cuatro religiones ucranianas
ocupadas cantaron Victoria tras cinco
días de referéndum con resultados que
señalan abrumadoras mayorías en favor
del sí
jerson
apuntan a anexarse a Rusia como para
crimea en 2014 la duma debería
formalizar la integración de las
regiones al territorio ruso Este martes
la comunidad internacional condenó
fuertemente los referendos que tilda de
Zarza
por lo tanto estamos presentando una
resolución con Albania que condena los
falsos referendos y pide a todos los
estados que no reconozcan ningún estatus
alterado de Ucrania y obliga a Rusia a
retirar sus tropas de Ucrania
inmediatamente
sin embargo Rusia al ser un miembro
permanente del Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU tiene el poder de vetar dichar en
solución y por el contra defiende un
proceso transparente
el referendo que se llevó a cabo
exclusivamente de manera transparente
respetando todas las normas electorales
Este es un hecho indiscutible
en el proceso con soldados desplazándose
de puerta en puerta para pedir el voto
en las urnas
ocupados ni siquiera se puede llamar
imitación de un referendo lo que se iba
a proclamar como resultado se conocía De
antemano la cifras acortadas para esta
farsa se filtraron a los medios de
comunicación
las personas que viven en estos
territorios ocupados y dijo que tras los
referendos No hay motivo para dialogar
con Vladimir Putin